Zach do you feel an actor has control
over their career in Hollywood I don't
does an actor have control over their
career okay that's a really hard
question to answer you have options that
you can try and execute but unless
you're producing directing and
distributing you really don't you you
have to do the best you can and let the
chips lay where they lay because it's so
much that you can't control and he had
Academy award-winning actor Sir Ben
Kingsley playing in the film and I
learned a big lesson from that film
which is that a crappy director can make
sir Ben Kingsley look like a crappy
actor so when Sir Ben Kingsley Academy
Award winner looks like a half ass in a
feature film you know it's not Sir Ben
Kingsley's job that he didn't do it's
the rest of the process so you try to
generate as much content as you can you
can control the scripts you involve
yourself with if you have the money to
pay the rent otherwise you can try and
tweak out the scripts you work on with
changing the dialogue or make and
bringing your a-game when it comes to
acting and helping out with the
choreography and really being on set
knowing your blocking but once you walk
off that set they can do whatever they
want to with your material and you have
no control over that
unless do you want to shoot everything
yourself which nowadays is an option
though when I was a kid man up till what
10 years ago eight years ago that wasn't
so maybe nowadays yes back in my day
no guy sounds all this great
you